Noel, I've got the greatest opening
for the final of the Bake Off.
OK, talk me through it. I've got
this cannon. And what happens is,
you get in the cannon and I fire you
out of it. Fire me out of
the cannon? It's not that difficult.
It's not exactly rocket science.
Well, obviously, it is actually...
Anyway, I've got this giant match.
I light... Is it a giant match or
are you just quite small?
Could you just get in the cannon?
This is not the helmet
I would've chosen.
Hm. Right, just climb
up, climb in, OK.
I'm not sure about this.
I'm lighting it now.
Here we go.
Argh!
Oh, my shins!
Oh, um...
Welcome to the final
of The Great British Bake Off.
Sandi? Yeah?
I think I'm stuck in this tree.
I'll get a ladder.
When?
You know... eventually.
In the beginning of our
tenth year...
It's gonna sink, it's going to
sink, it's going to sink.
Oh, what a dog's dinner that is.
..we had a baker's dozen.
HE GROANS
Now...
David, David, David, David.
Ooh, thank you very much, Noel.
..there are three.
It's not fine, argh.
Shall I put it back in?
I don't know. I don't know.
Ow!
Phew.
Trying to stay calm but my heart is
like "dum-dum-dum-dum-dum".
Good luck. You too.
I woke up this morning and I was
just kind of like,
"Oh, my God, it's the final -
like, it's here."
Argh.
Panic mode.
At times, Alice has let the stress
of competition get to her...
Breathe.
..but she's got stronger
as time's gone on...
I think that's a fine piece of work.
..winning her second
Star Baker last week.
Alice. Well done.
Will the demands of the final
see her flustered?
There's going to be a lot of
flapping - let's be honest -
but it would be insane,
like, it would be amazing to win.
This is it,
and no, I can't believe it.
Clever.
From the very beginning,
Steph showed great talent
and a flair for flavours.
It tastes lovely, it looks lovely.
Her skills have seen her win
a Hollywood handshake...
Steph. Steph.
..and landed her Star Baker...
Steph.
..an incredible...
..four times...
How are you? I'm stressed.
..but a lack of confidence has been
her biggest obstacle.
It's a battle of many things,
but who doesn't want to win it?
Come on, baking fairies.
Jump on my shoulders.
I've had daydreams about winning
Bake Off for ten years.
David's exquisite presentation has
impressed the judges.
It looks absolutely amazing.
His downfall has been
his flavours...
It's been overwhelmed by the spices.
..seeing him miss out on Star Baker
time after time.
I'm definitely the underdog.
Alice and Steph with all their Star
Bakers, all sparkly -
they're sparkly girls.
I want to just enjoy
everything about this weekend
and if I win, I win.
Three remaining bakers facing three
final challenges
before one is crowned the
Great British Bake Off Winner 2019.
Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
Congratulations. Whoo!
You're in the final. Ah.
I cannot believe we made it.
I can't believe I made it.
No, and I wrote
lots of letters about it.
Uh, for this wonderful signature
we would like you to make
the ultimate chocolate cake.
Now, obviously, it is
the Grand Final, so it needs
to be a masterpiece -
The Mona Lisa of chocolate cakes.
By that, we mean a chocolate cake
that looks like
a green woman with no eyebrows.
Exactly that.
Your cake needs to be creative,
it needs to be impressive
and beautifully decorated to
a professional standard.
You only have two hours.
On your marks... Get set... Bake.
Oh, it's just such madness that the
final has now started
and we're in it.
Oh, crazy.
I'm really excited.
I just need to get this
cake in the oven super fast.
Got so many things going on.
Chocolate cake - it sounds
so simple -
but we don't want a bog-standard
chocolate cake.
What we want is something which is
really chocolaty,
really decadent, absolutely
astonishingly good flavour and
of course it's got to be decorated
to be worthy of winning the final.
I think using cocoa is a possibility
but I'd like to see chocolate
in there as well.
Don't make this easy, do they?
The baking is integral on this.
Keeping them all even
and making sure it's all beautiful
on the outside as well as the in.
It's gonna be all about timing.
You've got to get it right, there is
no room for error.
Two hours is quite tight.
Right. This is a rich cake.
The one thing I don't like is when
chocolate cake doesn't taste
of chocolate -
it's just a sponge that's brown -
brown sponge -
not my thing.
Their choice of chocolate will not
only determine
the intensity of their
sponge flavour...
A chocolate cake should be moist
and rich.
..but the all-important texture too.
My favourite chocolate cake I've
just always done is this recipe
and it's just cocoa powder.
There is quite a lot of it
in there...
..so it does make it almost
a bit fudgy.
Hello, David. Hello, Paul.
Hello, David. Hey, guys.
You're in the final. Yeah.
Tell us about your grand final
chocolate cake.
So, my chocolate cake is going to be
prune with Armagnac.
Lovely. The chocolate - what are
you using?
I'm going with the 70% cocoa
solid chocolate inside the cake,
and cocoa powder as well, then it's
dark chocolate for the ganache
and dark chocolate for the mirror
glaze. Wow.
David's indulgent dark chocolate
cake will be flavoured with
Armagnac and vanilla syrup
and filled with Armagnac cream
to complement prunes soaked in even
more Armagnac.
Where's the prunes?
The prunes are inside the sponge.
Is it well distributed or do you
find it tends to
lump round in the bottom?
It kind... I don't know...
That's a trick question.
You know what? They should go
really, like, mushy into the cake.
Right. So if the prunes go to the
bottom, we won't know anyway. Yeah.
Thank you very much, David.
Good luck. Cool, thank you. Thanks.
Also getting fruity with her Grand
Final chocolate cake is Alice.
I don't really know how many
pears I'm using -
quite a few.
..but she's making sure it
stands out.
So, there's pears in the batter,
there's pears in between the layers
and then there's poached pears
on top.
It's interesting to see how
the pear's going to work
with the chocolate. You normally get
that almost like a pudding... Hm.
..so to see it in a cake it's
going to be interesting.
Alice's pear-packed ginger-flavoured
chocolate sponge will be
decorated with a dark chocolate
ganache drip,
maple cream cheese buttercream
and shards of hazelnut brittle,
as well as pears
poached in red wine and cinnamon.
Got to get the combination of all
the flavours spot on.
I think they seemed
to like the ideas.
You never really know,
though, how much they give away.
Ooh, I'm all nervous now, urgh.
When it comes to her
chocolate cake flavours...
Sometimes we just have to
acknowledge the true classics.
..Steph isn't taking any chances.
My chocolate cake is going to be
a black forest chocolate cake.
It's a '70s dream, innit? It is
something that used to get
wheeled round with your prawn
cocktail and your steak.
That came round as well with your
cheeseboard. Thought that was
pretty cool. And me pushing the
trolley. Are you trolley dolly bird?
Steph's retro cake will be
coated in chocolate ganache
and full of classic black forest
flavours with cherry jam
and kirsch-spiked Chantilly cream.
Gold leaf gilded cherries
will finish her Grand Final
signature bake.
It probably is the most important
cake I've had to bake
but Mum would just be saying,
"Just enjoy it, stay calm."
I definitely couldn't have done this
without my mum's support.
That's what's made it all the more
possible for me I think.
My God. So embarrassing.
Just got resting misery
face from you, didn't I?
I know.
Bake Off is not the first time
Steph's mum has been cheering
her on from the side-lines.
I couldn't wish for a better
daughter than Steph.
I cannot tell you how close we are
and this experience has
probably brought us closer together
out of anything cos I've had
to do an awful lot of washing up
and scraping her off the floor.
It's gonna be absolutely
perfect. Yeah.
She was not in a good place this
time last year.
Not knowing what to do
with her life,
and she started to cook things
and it helped her.
But the experience of being
in Bake Off - it's life-changing.
If people could see how far she's
come as a person
they wouldn't believe it.
She's got it all and doesn't think
she's got anything.
And there's no reason why
she can't win.
I'd just cry.
I would. I'm crying now at the
thought of it.
Cheers, Steph.
All the luck in the world, darling.
Oh!
You'd have thought I'd be capable of
anything after this, wouldn't you?
Nerves still very much jangling.
Oh, what are we going to do about
your confidence? I know, I know.
I think I used to get like it with
athletics as well.
I was always nervous that I was
going to hit a hurdle,
which I did do this one time.
Got to the last hurdle
and I was like, "I'm never going to
get over that,"
so I just went through it and then
did a tumble turn, sort of got up...
Ooh, is like dropping your cake
at the show stopper? Oh, please.
Please, you've just said it.
OK.
In we go.
23 minutes or
until a skewer comes out clean.
With time slipping away...
I'm in after 25 minutes
so five minutes ahead.
..the bakers'
ultimate chocolate cakes...
Ooh, a lot of butter.
..are about to get even
more indulgent...
Look how glossy
and beautiful that looks now.
..with the creation
of their luxurious fillings.
I'm making my ganache icing.
Growing up, if we had cake you only
had icing if it was a birthday cake.
My mum likes to remove every
bit of sugar and fat and it's quite
funny cos then she complains that
a recipe isn't good. It's like,
"Well, that's not the recipe. You've
just removed half the ingredients.
That is the perfect consistency,
isn't it? That's wonderful.
I would've gone like that.
That's wonderful, though.
David's been honing his baking
skills from an early age.
When all the children were very
little, we always baked,
and he was always very able
and very creative. First class.
Outstandingly good, wasn't he? Yeah.
He was doing art and design
for a year,
then he decided he didn't want
to go into that world
and he turned to nursing.
He would rather do something and
make a difference to people's lives.
We're very proud of what he's done.
We think the world of him, don't we?
Think he's great. Yes, yes.
He's just worked very, very hard,
so he's working his job
but then also he's
preparing for Bake Off all the time
so I think that can be a lot,
but he's been just super driven
and just gone for it.
To David, the baking genius
because of mum's food snobbery.
I'm also putting Armagnac
in the ganache,
so this was full when we started,
and I've not finished yet.
Sandi, what you doing? What?
It's the final, you need to look
a bit cooler, yeah? Oh.
Sunglasses on. Oh, sorry.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Halfway through.
What are those?
You look like the secret love child
of Timmy Mallet and a bumblebee.
Right, where are we?
Got all that, that, that.
Oh, doing too many things at once.
Not only do David, Steph
and Alice have to constantly
check their sponges...
Should be OK.
..and fillings...
Yum.
..to truly impress Prue and Paul...
You always make me so nervous.
..their cakes will have to
look as flawless
and decadent on the outside as
they are on the inside.
I'm making poached pears.
They sit on top of the cake.
Whoops.
Making a mess.
Wouldn't be me if I didn't make
a mess everywhere, would it?
Would you just explain, Alice,
what you've done?
I put some scales on the little
chocolaty fish.
There's no mess.
I think you've tidied
up before this was taken.
I know.
Alice has been baking and decorating
cakes since she was a child.
Baking is her passion.
She finds it very easy to put
the effort in
and the discipline in.
We've always taught Alice to prepare
well, think things through.
The magic words we
have for her is good management.
With good management you don't
need good luck.
You were determined to win
that trophy.
She can win it, she'll go out there
and give it her absolute best.
We are so proud of her.
Love her to bits and wishing her
lots and lots of good management.
What?
Don't laugh at me.
This is me in my natural state, OK?
Panic attack.
I'm having a panic attack.
Just don't get too close.
Just pray for me.
Baking fairies, pray for me.
OK, I'm just going to take one out
and check.
Yes.
So, they're all coming out.
I just don't know
if this one's done.
I'm worried that it's not
baked properly.
You can smell the Armagnac.
It's all about chilling time now.
Oh, yeah, I think it's fine.
Oh, no, it's not, it's not fine.
Argh. Shall I put it back in?
I don't know. I don't know.
One thing I forgot.
Shall I just bake another one?
No, cos it won't cool in time,
silly idea.
This is a syrup that I forgot to do.
It's just more Armagnac.
David, David, David, David.
Ooh, thank you very much, Noel.
That's my thing.
I'll start again.
I'm going to have to put it
back in.
This is a little bit unconventional.
Oh, I really hope that just pulls
itself together.
You do the time call, I'll pretend
to be the Scream by Edvard Munch.
Seems reasonable.
Bakers, you have half an hour.
Oh, assembly time.
I don't want loads and loads
of cream here, it's very strong.
Definitely has a kick.
As straight as it can be.
I think it's done.
If I can get it cool, I'll use it.
If I can't, I'm not using it.
Oh, I just feel all urgh.
Last week was the first time
I ever did a mirror glaze.
This is the first time I'm doing
a chocolate mirrored.
This has got to go down to 32.
At the moment it's at... 47.
That's gotta
go down a hell of a lot.
Could I have some ice?
Who did you say that to?
There's nobody there.
Weird, just talking to people. Yeah.
OK. I'll get you some ice.
OK, how long do we actually have
left? Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
Argh!
It's cold, thank God.
I'm going to start putting it
all together.
This can be my middle layer.
Hopefully you won't see it too much.
Phew.
Last week right at the end
I just rushed it
and Paul picked up on that.
Why are you doing this to me?
It's just leaning.
Oh, my God, I'm shaking.
Can you see my reflection?
Yeah, I can.
I think it's that middle layer.
Trying to stay calm but my heart
is like, "dum-dum-dum-dum-dum".
Bakers, you have one minute.
It's nearly there.
Maybe if I cover it in ganache
they won't notice.
Think that's me finished.
Oh, this is just not fun.
Whoa. It's kind of stuck to the
paper of the cake board.
Bake Off final, everyone.
Just going to have to put
it across anyway.
Bakers, time is up.
Done!
Please place your luscious
masterpiece chocolate cakes
at the end of your benches.
I've made a million cakes in my life
and this is the one that matters.
Maybe it will taste nice?
It's judgment time for the bakers'
final Signature Challenge.
Hello, David.
Hi, David. Hi, David. Hi.
I think it's quite effective.
It's a really good shine.
And the leaves actually look
quite nice on it as well.
Can't wait. Come on, give us a bite.
Let's have a look.
Look at that.
It looks very good inside.
You can smell the Armagnac,
can't you?
Mm.
And that Armagnac,
you wouldn't miss it, David.
Is there enough?
There's slightly more than enough.
I think when you do hit
a prune, it is delicious.
I think all your textures
are beautiful
but all you're getting is alcohol.
It is so boozy that you can only
eat a tiny, little bit of it.
So a bit of ice cream or something?
Would that work?
Hmm.
Chocolate ice cream probably.
Thank you very much. Thanks, David.
Thanks, guys.
First impression, it's a bit wobbly.
Hmm.
And it's a bit clumsy.
I like the dripping effect.
I think it looks quite nice and
there is a bit of a shine there.
There's a lot going on on the top.
You're usually so delicate.
OK. But it may taste fantastic.
Let's see, shall we?
The knife's going in
beautifully there.
Wow.
The texture of the cake's lovely,
isn't it?
Mm.
Very light.
You didn't have, real chocolate
in this, did you? No.
Cocoa.
Do you think it could be
more chocolaty? Yeah.
I'm lacking the chocolate actually.
OK.
Because you've got maple,
because you've got a little bit
of ginger,
because you've got pear and then you
put a cocoa in there,
it's a great cake. Yeah.
But is it a great chocolate cake?
I think it's delicious.
I think there's a really good
balance between chocolate and pear
and ginger. My main problem with it
is actually the way it looks.
Yeah. Not the way it tastes.
Thank you, Alice. Thank you
very much. Thanks, Alice.
It's very '70s.
It's a sort of old-fashioned cake.
But that's what you were doing
and you've done it beautifully.
It's very elegant but let's have
a look inside, shall we?
Three pretty distinctive
layers in there.
Yeah, cherry jam looks beautiful.
That's a Black Forest gateau.
You've certainly got
the chocolate there.
And the cherries
and the cream work well together.
There's a good balance.
It's very crumbly, that cake.
I think it is slightly overbaked
but the flavour of
the chocolate is delicious.
It's a very nice cake, Steph.
OK, thanks. Very good. Thank you.
Thanks, guys.
STEPH: Slightly like,
"Urgh, that's annoying."
I always want it to be perfect.
Just got to remember to
try and enjoy it.
There was too much alcohol. It
would've been a hard thing to do
to just be like, "I'm just
gonna do chocolate."
Maybe I should've done that.
The technical for the final,
there's no theme this week.
It could literally be
anything... which is terrifying.
I hope they don't throw
a massive curveball.
For our final three bakers,
the pressure is about to rise.
Right, bakers, welcome to your
very final Technical Challenge.
Today it's been set for you
by the delight that is Paul.
Paul, any words of advice?
On this challenge,
you have to be delicate.
OK, as ever, I have to ask these
two numpties to leave the tent.
Off you pop, kids. Bye.
That's you two.
Hello. All right.
Sorry. I couldn't keep it up, Paul.
LAUGHTER
Ah, that was like a weird dream.
OK, today, Paul would
love you to make six
twice-baked Stilton souffles.
Your souffles need
to hold their shape
when they're turned out of the mould
but they need to be delicate
and fluffy in texture.
And each one must be served
with a thin lavosh cracker.
You have an hour and ten.
On your marks. Get set. Bake.
Bake!
I've got a friend. We were living in
a flat together and he was looking
for his souffle dish and it turned
out I'd used it as a plant pot.
I'd no idea what it was.
It's probably one of
the hardest technicals.
Very limited time, shaking like
a leaf, all the standard stuff.
Help me.
Paul, this is the final
and you've given us
a twice-baked Stilton souffle.
Why?
I wanted something that
was gonna challenge them
but also had a very
classic feel to it.
What we're looking for are
very proud, tall souffles
with a gorgeous golden-brown colour
coming from the cream
and the Parmesan.
What could go wrong then?
When you're making a souffle
what you've gotta remember is
whisking your egg whites.
If you don't whisk them enough,
it's not gonna carry the air
but, again, if you overbeat it,
you're gonna have a similar
problem.
Be delicate with that mixture.
They could be underbaked
when we tip them out.
Therefore when they coat them
with the cream and the Parmesan,
you're gonna be coating a splat.
They need to concentrate
and watch their ovens.
It's a bigger piece for you there,
Prue. I'm a bigger girl.
But you see the air holes in it.
It's quite a stable
structure as well.
And then you have these
gorgeous lavosh biscuits
which are really wafer thin.
A few bubbles all over it
and a great snap as well.
I'm hoping we're gonna come up with
something that at least tastes good.
Oh, I think they'll be lovely.
I think this is first, isn't it?
Make a roux.
A roux is what people think of
if they're making a white sauce.
It's used as the base of a souffle.
You melt your butter,
add your flour.
I hope the roux will thicken.
We can hope.
I just don't know how thick
it should be.
Don't wanna overdo it.
So this is getting
quite nice and thick.
I just don't think
I've done this right.
What's the matter?
I just don't know if this is right.
Is this is a roux?
Have you never made a roux?
Really? You've never made lasagne,
fish pie?
Any of those things?
Sauce, bechamel sauce, no?
Lovely weather we're having,
isn't it?
Right, add Parmesan, mustard,
chives and thyme.
40g of this bad boy.
Just gonna give the thyme
a bit of a chop and a bash.
I haven't got time for this.
Beat in egg yolks and
mix in Stilton and seasoning.
In it goes.
Tasty? Tasty goodness?
Hmm.
It's like an advert from the '70s.
Yeah. Mmm, tasty goodness.
Let's have a taste. Go on, then.
Oh. Oh, tasty goodness.
OK great, that's brilliant. Yeah.
Right need to whisk my egg whites.
A souffle doesn't have
any raising agents
so all of the oomph
comes from the egg white.
It's not looking great.
A few lumpy bits in there.
I have these quite a lot.
I think I overwhip my egg whites.
It's like a stiff peak I think.
Does that look all right?
Hmm.
I'm gonna... Yeah,
I'm gonna leave it at that.
It looks quite airy. Have to get
them in the tins I think.
I don't know how much to
put in here.
This is not a 101
on souffle making.
How much should I put in, Noel?
Uh, oh, God.
You never put it all in
cos it would overflow.
I've got nothing. They're gonna
rise aren't they? That's the thing.
I think it doesn't
wanna be too much.
Doesn't wanna be too much
cos then they'll go pfft.
Yeah. Mushroomy.
This is a wing-it situation.
Think I need to probably fill it.
I need a bit of space at the top.
They are gonna rise up.
Fingers crossed.
This one looks like it's run out
of all the airiness so shame
for this little runt but this'll
be me in the family of souffles.
Bake using a bain-marie.
Cold water? Hot water?
Hot water in a tray in the oven.
Hot water in the bain-marie.
Just going for cold water.
They're ready for the first bake.
Right they're going in.
I hope it rises.
I don't know what is gonna happen.
Right, what have I got to do now?
Cos I feel like I'm way behind.
Bakers, you are halfway through,
halfway through.
I've not got long to double-bake
these and make the crackers.
Right, I'm making the dough.
It kind of sounds really crispy
and actually really delicious
so I'm happy to make one of these.
Plain flour,
wholemeal flour, olive oil,
salt and water but doesn't
tell you how much water.
Roll the dough until paper-thin.
Do we think this is paper-thin?
Now is this paper-thin?
Oh, that is paper-thin, darling.
Yes. That's like parchment.
You could write
the Dead Sea Scrolls on that.
I'd rather do that
than bake souffles.
Right 12 equal triangles.
How do we do this?
One thing that is never
my strong point is maths.
So I'm just gonna make a template.
Oh, God.
Don't wanna cut too much off.
So one, two, four, urgh.
How's David got so much?
Oh, these are too small now.
Oh.
Oh, this is a nightmare.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
I don't know that these
are gonna be ready
but I'm gonna have to do it now.
I think they feel solid enough
to actually take them out now.
I think I'm gonna have to
try and take them out.
Turn the souffles out on to
a baking sheet and leave to rest.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, God.
I don't think this is gonna
come out. I've got no choice.
That's something.
OK, keep going, keep going.
Oh, that one got a bit of bottom
on it. Mm-mm.
What a palaver.
Ooh.
Well, cold water in the bain-marie
was not a good idea.
This is a bit embarrassing
really, isn't it?
Oh, dear.
Pray for me.
I mean, like, do we keep going?
I just feel a bit stupid.
Bakers, you have five minutes left
to complete your Stilton souffles.
God, this was royally mean
with timings.
This is the second bake
but, look, it's a disaster.
Let's see.
This is horrific.
Oh, dear.
That is going in there as well.
These should
take like a minute to bake.
There's nowhere to put them but.
I can't fit 'em in, can I?
Bakers...
You have one minute left.
ALICE: Right, gonna get them out.
I don't know whether to just get
these out cos there's nothing
gonna change about this situation.
Panic stations.
What a disaster. Oh, dear.
It couldn't have gone much worse,
could it?
They're raw.
Seen better things in my life.
NOEL: Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring you souffles
up to the table
and place them
behind your photograph.
Prue and Paul are looking for
six beautifully-risen souffles
accompanied by crisp
lavosh crackers.
We'll start with these.
These are risen. A little bit...
Pale. ..pale and the biscuits
are a bit floppy.
They were brought out
the oven too early. Yeah.
The souffle's got a little
bit of bounce to it.
It could've done with longer
in the oven
but there is some substance there.
I mean, it's stable enough.
But you can tell right in
the middle there it's underbaked.
Good flavour. Texture's too gluey.
If that was served to me at lunch
I would eat it with a great deal
of pleasure
but this is the final of
The Great British Bake Off.
Right. Moving on to these, uh...
Pancakes.
..soups? Yeah.
The biscuits are too thick.
And not baked enough. That's hardly
been in the oven. Look.
Yeah. They've had problems with
the souffle from the start.
They've beaten the whole
thing to death.
Because those ingredients are
so delicious, it tastes lovely.
But it's like eating a sauce.
Now these look fairly substantial.
CRUNCH
Yeah, crack. There is a break.
Lovely and thin.
They're not bad.
Nice colour. Yeah.
And they are baked through.
It's very much better but
they're still not a perfect shape.
Mm. That is delicious. Mm.
They're well baked, them.
Prue and Paul will now
rank our finalists' souffles
from worst to best.
OK, in third place is...
..this one.
I'm so sorry.
Your biscuits are too thick
and your souffles,
did they actually hit the oven?
I used cold water in my water bath.
Cold water? Yeah.
Oh, bad luck, Steph.
In second place...
..is this one.
Alice, these are a bit raw and
the souffle,
they're a little bit uneven
and could've done with
a bit more cooking.
Yeah.
So in first place, David.
Souffles are pretty good
but you need to bake these longer.
But not bad effort actually.
I just hope the baking fairies
are back for me tomorrow.
I think they might have gone off
for a drink already.
They need to come back in.
Everything's just
been like mediocre today.
Clumsy cake, gluey souffle.
Got to make tomorrow like
the best thing I've ever made.
Tomorrow, knowing that there's
gonna be all our friends
and family outside,
and it's the very last time
we can do anything
to impress anyone,
yeah, that's high pressure.
There's just one more Showstopper
for our final
three bakers to complete.
Afterwards,
at a special carnival party in
front of their family and friends,
we'll find out
this year's Bake Off champion.
But Alice has received
an upsetting phone call.
Why was it cancelled?
Are they all cancelled?
Can you not get
a flight from Dublin?
Her mum and dad might not
be able to make it.
I'm a little bit upset because my
parents are coming back from Ireland
this morning and their flight's
just been cancelled.
And the thought of them not being
here when I walk out is just,
yeah, my worst nightmare really.
So I think the most consistent thing
about the entire series
is the number of times
we've sat here and gone,
"It's all down to the Showstopper,"
because I think it is again.
It's literally little things now.
I think in the Signature
Steph did OK,
flavours came through beautifully
and it did look amazing.
It looked fantastic.
And then you have Alice -
didn't look immaculate
but it did taste good.
David, I think where he let himself
down was literally the Armagnac.
I actually think David
did a decent souffle.
David's was a lot better
than the other two.
For all the bakes they've done,
this is the one that'll count.
Yeah. They need to concentrate.
There's a lot of stuff going on -
it's the final, families are coming
down, we've got a helter skelter.
That's distracting. I'm gonna go
on the helter skelter. Yeah.
Go on it now? Yeah. I think the
four of us. In one sack.
In one sack. That's your
money shot right there.
Hello, bakers.
It's time for your
last ever challenge.
Today the judges would like you to
make a deliciously deceptive feast
in the form of a picnic basket
and its contents.
Your feast must contain
elements made from cake,
enriched bread and biscuit.
The items in the basket
should deceive the eyes.
In other words, be made of one kind
of food but look like another.
So basically we're
testing the theory
that we actually eat with our eyes.
I've been doing it for years.
It's messy but it's OK.
Now, I do not need to remind you
this is your last chance to
impress the judges
so you're going to need to display
exceptional creativity
and technical skills.
You have four and a half hours.
On your marks. Get set. Bake.
My parents would hate the fact
that I was upset
because they weren't going
to be here so... focus.
There's so many elements today,
it's gonna be absolute
carnage in here, absolute carnage.
The bread's gonna look like a cake
and then the cake's
gonna look like bread.
It's gonna be all sorts
of confusion for you.
I think the final challenge
is all about deception.
They could make a bread roll
look like a pork pie.
They could make a cake
look like a banana.
But it's the final Showstopper.
It's got to taste
AND look fantastic.
All the techniques
and all the decorations
that the bakers have dealt with
over the last ten weeks
are sort of summed up in
this one Showstopper
and what we want is
really good bread,
really good cake,
really good biscuits.
So 29 challenges down, one to go,
and this is the big one for them.
May the best baker win.
Hi, David. Hello, David.
Hello. Morning.
So tell us about your picnic.
I'm making a cheeseboard
out of biscuit and then making
cheeses out of lemon pound cake
and then I'm making breads to look
like little peaches flavoured with
saffron and orange blossom water.
Bingo. Bingo!
THEY LAUGH
It's honestly the only
spice in the whole thing.
NOEL: David's edible illusion picnic
will feature boozy fruit cup jellies
to accompany his peaches
made out of lightly spiced bread,
lemon pound cake cheeses
and fig rolls that look like
savoury sausage rolls.
I'm starting on my bread dough
cos that takes quite a while.
Nik, my partner,
it's been his birthday this week
and I had no time to
celebrate with him.
So this could be
his birthday picnic.
One thing done.
David's not the only
one celebrating.
Ooh, gotta pop the prosecco.
I love teaching, don't get me wrong,
but I love the summer holidays,
a lot.
So this is kind of my
end-of-the-school-year
celebration picnic.
Tempted to just pour myself a glass.
Alice is turning her celebratory
prosecco into jellies
to go with strawberries made out
of raspberry flavoured macarons,
orange and cardamom ice cream
bread buns and pork pie,
chicken drumsticks and Scotch eggs
all created from carrot cake.
So the most important question -
who's coming to support you today?
OK, so my parents...
Don't cos you'll make me cry again.
They were at a wedding in Ireland
yesterday... Sorry, you made me cry.
Oh, sweetie. Um, the flight was
cancelled this morning
so I just really hope they make it.
But I'm so embarrassed to cry.
Oh. Oh, darling.
Are they swimming then?
I hope they swim or whatever to get
here, I just hope they're here.
Yeah. I couldn't imagine it
without them.
Biggest day of my life
and everything, so...
As soon as they arrive
I will make sure you know, OK.
Good luck, Alice.
Thank you very much.
Once I start crying,
I'm gone, like, I am gone.
Right, focusing again.
NOEL: After struggling with
yesterday's technical...
I really do feel like
I'm baking for my life.
..Steph's hoping there won't be
any more tears today.
The dough looks different
to how it should do
but I'm just gonna try and
avoid those negative thoughts.
Steph's hopes of winning are
all pinned on her illusion picnic
featuring spiced orange bread buns
turned into fairy cakes
and macaron strawberries.
Her savoury looking centrepiece
will be a lemon poppy seed cake
chicken burger.
I called you Mowgli. How are you?
I'm trying not to panic too much.
Just wanna be able to
present something.
You will. You always do.
Yesterday was a bit touch
and go, wasn't it? Mm.
All right, well, look, carry on.
What is it...?
# You got a friend in me... #
Is that Toy Story?
Yes. Oh, I was thinking
it was Mowgli but... No.
I've still got a friend in
you then, haven't I?
Mowgli's Bear Necessities.
Yeah, sorry. Wrong film.
Let's see what happens. Let's see.
If you win, I'll let you stay
in the jungle for a bit longer.
OK, cool. You don't win,
I'll take you back to the man folk.
Yeah. Deal? OK, deal. Thanks.
Come on, you can do it. OK.
That's gonna prove for an hour
first time round.
Oh, sorry.
As their bread dough proves...
So much to do and so little time.
..the bakers can move on to
their picnic centrepieces -
the illusion cakes.
This is my lemon and poppy seed.
Quite a lot of lemon zest
so just gonna zest for our lives.
Well, we've reached the final, Prue.
I think it's gonna be fascinating
to see what they come up with.
I'm thinking of speed today so
this is kind of an all-in-one mix.
I'm a bit worried about Alice.
She's worried about whether her
parents will get on that plane.
She needs to just concentrate
on the plan and keep baking. Hmm.
So these are lemon spice drops.
So instead of having to sit and
zest a lemon, you can put these in
and it gives a really
intense lemon flavour.
I think David seemed to be
in a much calmer place. Yeah.
Always looks as if he's
enjoying himself, doesn't he?
He does seem the most chilled
out of the three. Yeah.
Doesn't taste lemony enough
so must need more lemon.
I just really want
all three to do well
because if you just crash out,
it's horrible. I totally agree.
Ooh.
There's only gonna be one Bake Off
champion. Who's it gonna be?
No idea at the moment.
No, me neither.
These are going in.
I think it tastes of lemon.
I don't know.
I think I'm gonna
have to go with it.
On 180 for about 30 minutes.
OK, right let's clear
some stuff out the way.
This is unheard of.
Bakers, you've got three hours left.
Ooh. Keep going.
With their breads...
These are gonna prove again.
..and cakes under way...
Need a bit longer.
..the bakers can begin their
final picnic transformation.
The biscuit.
What you folding that with?
Um, hmm?
Wooden spoon.
I might get a spatula.
Fig rolls are my favourite biscuit.
It's funny cos when we did it
at biscuit week,
Jamie put an egg wash on his
fig roll and Paul joked that
it's like a sausage roll
so I was like, "Ah, OK, perfect.
"Well, I'll make sausage rolls."
So I'm making my macarons.
Strawberries and tomatoes
but they're gonna be raspberry
and lemon flavoured.
I think Steph's also doing
strawberry macaron.
That's OK. Everyone has
strawberries at picnics.
This is the Italian method
that I did last week.
I can't make them using
the French method.
These are gonna go in the fridge.
I need to let them
rest for half an hour.
SANDI: But there'll be
no rest for the bakers.
Uh, where am I up to?
Very much multi-tasking now.
And this is all about illusion,
isn't it?
So I don't wanna rush decoration.
Cakes are looking good.
So they're all coming out.
They're quite caramelised
and colourful.
No, it's still lovely
and soft in the middle.
Wow.
Oh, that's so dry.
Urgh, God.
How bad can things go wrong?
Steph's cake isn't her only problem.
Oh, it's...
Her macarons aren't going
to plan either.
I think that's too liquid.
I haven't got time to redo it.
Look at the state of it.
It's just so bad.
All of it.
I don't know how
I can get through it.
Ow.
You all right? No, sorry. I'm having
a real... Don't be sorry. ..stress,
I've just got too much to do.
You've gotta dig deep. I am.
This is the last time you're
gonna do this. I'm gonna try.
You've won Star Baker four times.
I know. You've got this.
Keep going. OK, thank you. Calm.
Calm? I'm trying to. Calm. Calm.
Whee!
Bakers, you're halfway through.
Stop mucking about, it's the final.
Urgh, it's like glue.
I still don't know that
that's worked properly.
I wouldn't say in control.
The worst bits are still to come.
Nougatine-gate.
As well as an array of
breads, cakes and biscuits...
I think I'm actually gonna start
my nougatine, which is terrifying.
..our three finalists have been
asked to make a nougatine basket
to display their illusion picnics.
So nougatine is a caramel that
encases lots of nuts or seeds
and goes really hard so I'm
using sesame seeds as my filler.
Starting to smell a little bit
burny so I think that's a good sign.
I'm just wiping down the edges
cos it's started to crystallise.
Oh, and that's a bad thing?
Yeah. Any news?
No news as of yet so... Oh, God.
Tears are coming again.
Eyes are like a tap.
Good luck, everyone.
Please work, nougatine.
So sticky.
So the key bit for this
is not getting burnt.
Ow. It's so hot.
That, I think, is ready.
This is what I'm gonna
mould my nougatine around.
This has gone really
badly in practice
so I just feel like this
is gonna be a disaster.
It's a bit skewwhiff but it's on
now.
Urgh. How do you do this?
I didn't make a handle at home.
I just presumed it was easy.
Don't do this to me.
Ooh, I should probably
do it a different way.
I mean, this is not a hamper.
I don't think a handle's
gonna happen.
Just burnt myself a couple of times
but everything looks clean and neat.
Oh, my...
He's insane, isn't he?
Tell you what,
your driving's getting better.
Thanks for teaching me. Yeah, no,
it's fine it's just...
It's not a criticism but I think we
took a slight wrong turn.
What do you mean? Well, we're
not in the funfair any longer.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Bakers, you have one hour,
just one hour.
Oh.
It's all a bit blurry really.
We were going quite fast. Yes.
My macarons - gonna go in for
about 12 to 14 I think.
I'm just worried about the macarons.
They need to form a film
over the top and that's how
when they rise they hold
their shape. But these are not.
I don't know whether
to do them again.
Maybe I have time, I don't know.
Her macarons might not be
going to plan
but there is some good
news for Alice.
Are my parents on the plane?
Yes.
Yay. Right, I'm gonna
start them again. OK.
OK. Go, go, go.
The buns are gonna be out in a
couple of minutes
and then these will go in.
Round two.
Let's just see how these ones go.
Right, move on.
I don't think my macarons are
properly baked. They're really bad.
It's just not my day, is it?
So this is how my cake
should've gone yesterday.
This one, however, needs to
look like a pork pie.
So this one is Cheddar.
So this is just toasted
coconut for my chicken burger.
So I'm just kind of crimp the edge
then I'm gonna spray paint it.
Just want to add a little
bit of texture to this one.
We're going for a golden bun look.
Right, there we go.
Pork pie done.
As far as I'm concerned,
that's cheese.
I'm just gonna make
this into a blue cheese.
Look at you, you're just straight in
there.
Boom. You're not scared, are you?
No.
You seem to be going great guns.
I'm gonna leave you alone.
Cool, thanks, Noel. I'll come
back when you're panicking
but I don't
think that'll ever happen. No.
SANDI: Bakers.
Half an hour left. Half an hour.
Go, Alice. Go, Alice.
I don't know if I'm gonna get it
done in half an hour
but just keep going. Never give up.
Some iced buns.
My peaches,
they were slightly overproved
so they've got
a bit of a rim round them.
My macarons,
they've kind of formed a seal.
Just gonna put the other
ones in as well. Oh, God.
They're slightly baked biscuits.
I don't have time to redo them.
That's fine.
Fill these Scotch eggs.
The buns look overbaked, just like
everything's a little bit overbaked.
Got literally everything done
apart from my macarons and if
I don't have them then I've not met
the brief so that's not good, is it?
Bakers...
You've got ten minutes left.
Ten minutes.
I'm not happy with
how I've baked stuff,
the overall look,
but it's not been my day.
Piece of wax paper for the cheese.
I know I don't have time for
this, gonna do it anyway.
Prue and Paul.
Right, well, they're awful
but there's something there.
They are looking delightful.
I'm gonna scrap the strawberries
and just do tomatoes.
Rustic is the order of the day.
Two, one, time.
Bakers, that is it for 2019.
Ooh.
Please place your picnic baskets
at the end of your station.
Well done, kids. You made it.
You did it.
Outside the tent our finalists'
family and friends have arrived
along with some familiar faces.
It's amazing to be back.
I'm so excited.
I feel like I need a nap.
I missed everyone massively. Feel
like I was missing out, bit of FOMO.
It's so lovely to see everyone.
We just need the last three out now.
My money's on... Essex.
I'm rooting for Alice.
For the boys, I'm going to back
Dave. Big Dave.
David is so knowledgeable.
To bring home the win today that'd
just be magical for him.
Steph's just obliterated that tent,
hasn't she?
I don't know, I don't know.
I, I couldn't call it today.
Any three of them totally worthy.
Oh, argh, I don't know. All of them.
I choose all of them.
They're all my winners.
It's judgment time for the
show-stopping edible picnic
illusions.
Alice, please bring up your
show stopper.
Not as strong as I thought I was.
I think that's exceptional.
Quite an impressive illusion.
Yeah, the Scotch eggs you do
believe that that's egg. That's
amazing.
The only thing that fail a little
on the illusion side are the ice
creams.
They're very good. they just don't
look totally convincing.
Let's have a look at the buns.
I don't think it really works cos
blueberries don't have much flavour
but they do look absolutely perfect.
And these are?
Carrot cake Scotch eggs.
So the egg is a lemon cream cheese
and then a lemon curd yolk.
Lemon comes through a little bit.
Hmm. Good carrot cake there.
Hmm, I think that's exceptional.
The illusion works,
it's funny and it tastes nice.
And these are the little macarons.
You only have got one strawberry
shaped.
I did have a few issues with
the macarons.
That's really strong flavour,
really fresh fruit.
Right, what is this?
It's orange and cardamom.
Love that, lot of zest coming off
that. Lot of zing.
It's a good texture as well
for an enriched dough.
Very clever
and I do like the taste of them.
Thank you very much, Alice. That's
a pretty good effort, well done.
Thank you very much, thank you.
David, please bring up
your show stopper.
I think it looks amazing. Stunning.
The basket is great.
It's even got mine
and Prue's initials on it.
The fig rolls have worked really
well as sausage rolls.
And that cheese looks incredible.
So what shall we start with,
the peach?
Yeah, let's start with the peach.
Oh, that looks lovely.
I like. That's really clever.
And the saffron does work well.
Yes!
And it took the final to get
there!
The texture's excellent as well and
the fruit just sets it off with
a little of zing aswell.
I think the flavours are very
interesting. But I think they're too
chewy.
Shall we try your fig rolls or
sausage rolls?
Very nice. That's very good as well.
And they look fantastic. Yeah, they
do.
The texture's so soft on the mouth
with the fondant
and with the buttercream as well all
together it is really delicious.
It's really delicious. You've come
up with something that is very, very
clever
and you've gone to the extra bit of
making the biscuit base and the
fondant,
the tablecloth, the chutney and
whole thing together is exceptional.
Bravo. Thank you.
Nailed it.
Steph, would you like to bring up
your show stopper please?
Apart from the basket having
had a few problems
I like the look of the burger. And I
would definitely think that was made
of bread.
I think there's obviously been
a few issues today.
The bun topping is not right and the
strawberries you need to get the
glisten on the top of them.
The bun I like, that looks
pretty good.
Nice hot cross bun. Delicious, love
the spice.
Need to prove a little bit more.
It's a little bit tight inside.
Those are not round enough for
strawberries. They're a bit flat.
My you've got a kick to that
Chantilly, haven't you?
What's in there? Cherry liqueur.
It's a little bit overwhelming.
Wow. That is really good.
It's clever. Very clever.
It's not much flavour to that.
Could've done with more lemon.
It's a little bit overbaked as well.
Never mind, Steph.
Thank you very much indeed.
Sorry.
Doesn't matter, all right?
I know, thanks.
You did a good job.
It's fine.
At the Bake Off funfair... Oh!
..the crowds are awaiting
Paul and Prue's final decision.
So it's very difficult for us cos we
just get to look at the cakes,
we don't taste them. If there was
one that you particularly loved
the taste of, which one would it be?
I liked Alice's.
And I liked David's.
I'm not sure what happened
to Steph today
because there are some issues
in every single element.
She'll be kicking herself. It was
heartbreaking really, wasn't it?
It was heartbreaking. I think
ultimately what we're looking at
is between Alice and David.
So, Alice has had Star Baker twice.
Yeah. David not at all.
I think the thing is with David,
they always look good
but it's whether it matches up with
flavour and textures, and, often,
it didn't but, in the final, it has.
But I'm going to remind you that his
signature was not your favourite.
If you're looking overall,
Alice has been very steady
in every single challenge.
Yeah. She has.
The Scotch egg is astonishing.
The look of it throws you totally
when you eat it.
Well, I think you two have still got
things to discuss, so,
while you do that, can I have
a sausage roll, please?
Yeah, of course, yeah. You do know
it's a fig roll, don't you?
Changed my mind.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Oh, my goodness,
there's loads of people!
Before the winner of
The Great British Bake Off 2019
is announced... Hey, Bakers!
..the Bakers can at last join their
family and friends.
Oh, my God!
I'm ecstatic that all my friends
and family are here.
So... I can relax now.
I was so scared you wouldn't come.
We wouldn't miss it for the world.
I've done 30 bakes in the Bake Off
tent and the last one went well.
So, really relieved and happy.
My darling, come here.
I'm proud of myself.
I really have gone above and beyond
anything I could have imagined.
I saved the worst till last.
Maybe ten weeks was just
one too many.
This looks amazing!
In other weeks, when I've done well,
I've never felt like
I've done the best.
So, I feel more nervous
than I have in any other week.
You've glazed your fig rolls, mate.
LAUGHTER
I'll be happy no matter what.
I would just like to be ecstatic.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Would the finalists
please step forward.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Thank you so much to all of you
for coming to support this wonderful
event and how lovely to see all
the Bakers returned to the tent.
I am delighted to tell you, after
ten weeks of intense competition,
the winner of the 2019
Great British Bake Off is...
..David.
RAUCOUS CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Well done, mate. You smashed it!
You smashed it. Just at the right
time. Don't smash that, though.
Well done, darling.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, thank you.
HE BREATHES OUT
I've watched this
since the second series,
so, for nine years, I've been
daydreaming about being on Bake Off.
It, honestly, it wasn't even
in my mind I could even win this.
So proud of you!
Week on week,
other people were stronger,
I was always the underdog
but managed to get through.
Just getting to the final was a win
for me. So, this is just unreal.
You nailed it in the final.
Yeah, just saved the best till last,
that's all I had.
David came as probably
the underdog into the final,
knowing that twice Alice has won,
four times Steph has won.
And he's come from nothing
and then won the whole thing.
I mean, it's priceless,
absolutely priceless.
He should be very proud of himself.
I think he's done an amazing job.
Thank you very much. Well done,
David. Thank you very much.
What are you going to do now?
I don't know!
David is an extraordinary baker.
I'm so full of admiration for him
because, right from the beginning,
he has never lost his temper,
he was always very neat
and very organised.
It was really a question of
the tortoise catching the hare
because he just steadily
went on and... and won.
Amazing! We are so proud of you.
You can have these, Mum.
David, just... You blew us out
of the water. The best baker won.
And I'm feeling great.
You did so well. I'm so happy.
I'm really proud of myself and I can
really leave with my head held high.
It's just the best feeling.
PRUE: Well done, Steph.
If you're going to have a bad day,
how better to make it all go away?
I've made some amazing,
lifelong friends.
Just the most incredible
experience ever.
HE SIGHS
It feels so good.
It's been weeks and weeks
of intensity and fatigue,
and then intensity, and to finish it
with this, I mean...
It's the best feeling in the world.
Well done, David. Thank you.
You got the bread, honey!
Are you a Star Baker in the making?
If you'd like to apply for the next
series of Bake Off, go to...
Subtitles by Red Bee Media